hello and welcome to Beth Rigby
interviews on this week's show as the
wild marks a year since Russia invaded
Ukraine I speak to a man who found
himself at the heart of the battle
Sean Pinner is a former British soldier
who joined the Ukrainian forces for
years before the war
he was captured along with a fellow
Britain accused of being a mercenary and
sentenced to death before being made to
plead for both their lives on Russian
television I beg on on my behalf and
Aiden azn's behalfa to help us in an
exchange
three months later having been tortured
and starved the pair were released in a
swap deal and returned to the UK
and we're now out of the danger zone and
were on our way home to our families
[Music]
foreign
er's Journey from the British home
counties to a Russian prison cell and a
death sentence began five years ago when
he moved to Ukraine settled there and
married having fought in the British
army he joined the Ukrainian National
Guard and then the Marines a month
before the War Began last February he
told Sky News just how committed to the
Ukrainian cause he was
the guys know I'm not you know a war
tourist or a war junkie and I'm with an
organized unit I'm with the government
and I'm with a contracted soldier I've
integrated so they know I'm not just a
like I said uh just sitting around and
going to go home at the end of it I've
been here my family's here my family's
15 kilometers I can hear the shelling
from my front room less than two months
into the war Sean was captured by the
Russians during the fall of mariopol and
along with fellow Britain Aiden Aslin
was charged with being a foreign
mercenary convicted and sentenced to
death but after five months in Russian
detention during which time he was
beaten electrocuted and barely fed Sean
was unexpectedly released in a prison a
swap deal brokered by Roman Abramovich I
spoke to him about his ordeal and his
hopes for the future of Ukraine
Sean thanks very much for talking to us
today now this week will Mark the first
anniversary of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and I want to talk to you today
about the heroism The Suffering The
resilience of the Ukrainian people
but personally for you it's kind of a
miracle you're actually even sitting
here given the fact you were captured
and what you went through because I mean
some people watch this might think you
ended up serving in the Ukrainian Army
as a sort of mercenary but you you're a
hard gun but you weren't that were you
no that was not what you would do no
initially for two years I was an
instructor of a National Guard uh worked
with their sniper teams and and
surveillance teams out there and then
after that the laws change within
Ukraine so I could do a three-year
contract to get my residency and by that
time I was looking at getting married
for almost nearly three years before The
Invasion took place I was out there
doing routine deployments with the first
Battalion and Marines the Ukrainian Army
so your friend sort of says come out you
go out
you start working you meet Larissa yeah
you're you're now wife
so before this happened the Russian
invasion you're now building your life
in Ukraine yeah this is where you're
gonna spend the rest of your life you
think yeah we learn the language yeah I
like Russia because most people in Mary
opal
um speak Russian so I was looking at
finishing that contract and then
starting to build my life in in Mario
Paul in between here England and and
Ukraine it was a brilliant life let's go
back to February the 24th what happened
in those first few weeks for you where
were you what happened how quickly did
it build up
um well we got stood two about four
o'clock in the morning and we knew
something was happening and you practice
this routine but this one was for real
you know my boss had just spoke speaks
really good English really good platoon
Commander leads by example uh says
you've got to get your positions uh
Russia come across the border
bloody hell it's on
um but well we were you what happens in
that moment is your is your you're
worried so much adrenaline yeah
everything your your adrenaline's going
you're nervous you're scared you know
part of people aren't scared I was
petrified uh it's Russia they told me it
wasn't my fault and they were gonna uh
move me back if I wanted to go uh
somebody said suggested that and I said
I've been with you for five years and my
home's in Mario Paul how could I live in
myself no they're defending at home and
I'm shipped out because I'm English back
off the front line Mario Paul I mean so
it's your home we all saw the pictures
the Russian Seas siege that began on
Mario Opel pretty soon after the War
Began and it went on until May didn't it
it was just yeah it was a beautiful city
and it was raised it was raised to the
ground by the Russian army
when you go back to those early days
what
was it unimaginable no combat experience
could uh to prepare you for that because
one uh whenever I'd fought anywhere I'd
always fought from a patrol base we had
air superiority oh yeah this is
different my friend described it to me
as we're now the guys in sandals we're
now the Taliban we're now Isis you know
this is how it was described to me and I
was like yeah you're dead right there
they'd just blown up at school when it
was there that really you saw the the
devastation that the Russians did all
the way to marry opal you've been in
combat a lot yeah had you ever seen
anything like this nothing
nothing like the the carelessness of it
the bombing of scores all the way back
from uh their front lines to marry opal
uh you know I saw a score with just the
kids uh coats hanging up and bags on
there uh where they've been evacuated
and put in a Cellar and they just hit
the school didn't care about it as a
professional Soldier
that must have been really hard because
there's kind of rules of combat right
yeah bombing Children's Schools yeah
yeah yeah you're used to combat yeah you
train for combat but now you're going
back and you're going home and you get
there
you've described it in the past as a a
zombie apocalypse yeah pretty much this
was in uh when we first pulled back to
Mario Opel late February early March
right okay so within two or three days
the whole city uh sort of had really
collapsed
um it was just they were hitting
apartment blocks the planes were doing
the most damage uh the Rockets you
became aware of the noise so so if you
heard the rocket coming in it's already
blown up so you're going to be safe you
take cover and then you just prayed
you'd heard that because it's already if
you don't hear that you're already dead
but sure at this point where's Larissa
and what's happening to your home I knew
she was okay yeah and I managed to get a
call out to her eventually after that
day and I think it's all over around
sort of March time and we're surrounded
we've got no food and if you don't hear
from me don't worry I'm not dead I could
be captured and and she just said fight
your Fighters uh survive she said you
brought the world's attention to Mary
opal
um you know keep going just survive and
she didn't cry she didn't she was
shouting down a phone really powerfully
um saying you guys are amazing you're
holding it just told us to fight and
survive
um so it was quite an emotional time
when you made that quarter then did you
think that was it for you yeah pretty
much so you all now
Under Siege or in the still works at
this moment you'll be in bombarded
within an inch of your lives had you
given up at that point and then she kind
of jeed you up again yeah definitely
yeah everybody goes for ups and downs
and trying to motivate people when
they're really surrounded and the only
way you're going to get is you're either
going to be dead or you're going to be
captured
um it's really hard to keep people
motivated you know we've gone down to
under a sewage works and split the team
in half so that just so that we could
escape the bombing and get some rest
um and the the bombing was just pounding
uh especially those final weeks and
they'd already been in Recon that's
already been into a three times killed
uh one of the guys in our team and by
the end of it the tanks were coming in
trying to blow holes through walls to
try and get their infantry through into
areas you've got no food no water yeah
they were just so close there were other
side of walls uh we could hear them
talking
um and we were just waiting for him to
come through and it was really really
scary you know so you're there you're in
the still works they're coming for you
you're like we are there's no there's no
way out of this no way so then
ultimately you try to break out you try
to escape
how does that have what how does it have
what happens is you prepare to leave
like how can you tell us what happened
we we were really on the last cusps of
of holding I mean the enemy had got
within 50 meters or 30 meters into all
positions that we occupied at the start
of the Mario Brothers we were then on to
maybe hand-hand combat and uh and so it
was very very close uh and I think my
commanding officer put out appear when
the Brigade Commander put out of the
pill and said look we went out of water
run out of ammo if you can't get here
we're gonna we're gonna have to
surrender
um and it was never an option for me
Michael took him out of my team to
surrender we were going to try and break
the first line and get out why was it
never an option
um being British I was never I didn't
want to surrender I knew that um they
couldn't basically encircle the whole
area there would be gaps and we all knew
that
um and we thought we'd take our chance
with it and my battalions uh had uh
orders to meet up with a sister
Battalion
um the 501st which was about 130
kilometers away
um so their plan was to try and get
there and join up with them and find our
way out
um
I'm trying to sort of think about how so
you're there thinking I'm not going to
be captured either Escape or die yeah
it's that that's where you get to know
yeah yeah yeah none of us wanted to get
captured so it was always on the cards
that we were going out the Battalion
Commander wanted the Battalion to try
and get out
so generally but once once the decision
had been made by zelenski to uh you
could surrender uh you can go try and
get back to Friendly lines or negotiate
your surrenders so Michael said we're
moving off we just drove out we made it
quite a way out for about 40 minutes
through Marie opal without a shot being
fired which is great and then we got
ambushed about 40 minutes out by
aircraft artillery and basically uh
there were small arms fire there was
casualties everywhere running around
platoons took off in all directions and
I was carrying I got asked to help by a
medic woman who was carrying an injured
officer for my platoon two of us helped
in and then we lost track of our platoon
in the dark because it was about three
in the morning when we decided to move
off the position so we lost them in the
dark and I was left with a medic
sergeant and her orderly another guy
from albertoon the injured guy and
injured people just came out of woods
like pixel zombies it was just uh crazy
they were just shuffling out really
injured bleeding so we moved them all
into a building near where we were
dropped off
um and inside the building where we
moved into were more casualties on
stretches silicon for any food can't see
in ukrainians don't know where anybody
is don't know where we are we've got no
wife I can't look on Google Maps I know
roughly where we are because I live in
Mary airport but I don't know the area
in detail so I said I'm gonna have to go
I'm British I need to file number two
um you you're qualified to take These
Guys these guys aren't going anywhere
outside it was one of the hardest
decisions I ever to make to leave them
um but my duty was that I was British I
didn't want to be caught
um and also my new my platoon was nearby
I'd lost them but I knew that maybe I
could find him so I went out and left
him it was a really hard decision to do
but I said I'm gonna have to go she just
went go and then you and you needed to
escape I needed to escape well I was
able I'd come out of that six weeks
fighting with not a scratch and most of
my platoon 60 my terms either injured or
killed I thought I can't find my platoon
I'm going to have to dump my body armor
my rifle I'm never going to make 200ks
without weight that ammo and I've not
eaten two weeks
um you know a solid meal so it's going
to be a long struggle
um and it's pretty hard to leave your
your big heavy stuff behind because as a
soldier you want to take it with you
everywhere you go and then I'd had a
plan if I was captured to surrender to a
Russian officer and all these ideas but
that all went to
to the Wayside when I got captured too
did you think at this point you might
make it yeah absolutely it did yeah I
was uh I was pretty sure I've seen
stories uh 12 guys did actually make it
the 200 kilometer tab I've lost my
platoon right hey ho so we've got a I've
got to try a new objective I've got to
try and get to Friendly lines eventually
I hit a road on there and then I could
try and find a way to zaparusian
Friendly lines
um and maybe I'll pick up some mobile
signal on the way and then I can get a
good idea where I am on the map when I
get out and then they captured me uh
just coming over the crest of this hill
I walked straight into a forward
observation point which could have been
a mortar crew or something like I didn't
even see him in the tree line they just
fired a warning shot of me which was
which I give me enough time to to duck
down and Chuck my phone into a pond and
uh and make sure I wasn't captured with
my phone and hold my hands up so now are
you thinking this is it I'm gonna die
yeah I pretty much planned to surrender
to an officer but they let call me
forward uh then I I was pretty much
taken to this what would be a section
commander on their position who drove me
to a company-sized place about 10
minutes away from where I was captured I
didn't put up a fight there wasn't any
point were you terrified at this point
Sean yeah absolutely you you you have to
control it but by that time you you know
what's coming you know you're going to
have to take a few licks you know what's
what I wasn't expecting was to be
stabbed in a leg by what looked like
Russian uh
place of some sort I knew the value of
me quite early doors I think okay so you
you're valuable to them because you're
also yeah Soldier right yes absolutely
okay so you're valuable but they then
beat you badly they still beat me badly
stabbed yeah they first of all the the
guys before they took me to what was
like a tiled flawed with uh looked like
a wet room
um the guy was wanted to see if I had
any right wing tattoos on me so stripped
me down started cutting off all my
clothes uh not before but straight away
just stabbed me in a leg and then
proceeded to do that
um he just went oh and he was just
bleeding everywhere all over my legs uh
I was screaming I know I haven't got any
right-wing tattoos and you know but he
just kept shouting Nazi and then
they took me for about I would say about
half hour 45 minute drive to a tiled
building uh tiled floor which was like a
wet room in an office where they just as
soon as I got there
these my legs to the chair like this and
then I felt the clips go on to my little
fingers which I knew instantly what that
was and then they didn't say anything
for a bit what was that sure well they
um they first guy said you want to phone
home and I didn't quite understand the
connotation and then I had 200 volts
going through me on the chair I couldn't
feel my leg anymore I was literally
standing up in the spot electrocuted me
in there and they didn't really ask me
any questions it was like you're a Nazi
your MI6 your essay yes sure and it was
just really they weren't really after an
answer everything was you're lying you
know and then it electrocute me two or
three more times after that with this um
this wind up telephone not telephone
yeah I assume it was I don't really
excruciating yes you feel like your
muscles are popping out if you're
um your body and the next day my legs
inflated uh very badly uh the blood was
coming from capillaries were going uh
leaking blood through my legs when I
took my thermal off I was just bleeding
from the leg from electric shocks and my
legs had inflated to about I couldn't
walk they were about this big
um and yeah it was very tough they'd
actually not got a good grip on my
little finger so they put them on my
thumb as well and then started to
electrocute me on the thumb
which was really really intense but all
the time because I could hear Russian
they were saying his Person of Interest
he's we wanted moved off so I knew I had
to get through that provided a heart
attack or anything I just had to really
get through the the pain of that and the
beating where they punched my leg where
it just been stabbed so then they played
me back the video of me getting
electrocuted we had a Ukrainian flag on
me I don't even remember putting on it
they'd put uni yellow and blue tape over
my head so I couldn't see and then he
said this is you you're dead on the
internet they showed me a picture of my
passport which had deceased on it which
they then sent around on the internet
and then they said you're dead on the
internet and then he showed me playback
of my torture which was really uh really
and I was kind of hoping please post it
please post it I'll still look for it
now so it's so it can add to the
evidence of of war crimes of war crimes
basically when when they said we you're
deceased on the internet do you then
think oh no one's going to come and get
me well it didn't I didn't you just
you're just out of it at this point I
didn't know I spoke a little bit of
Russian so I could hear somebody on the
phone saying yeah he's one it is a
person of interest so I was really by
that time after sort of two electric
shocks dribbling on my own chest and
twitching so when they played back the
video there was me just twitching my
arms just twitching through the the
muscle was Contracting uh I couldn't
really string two words together it was
just uh I remember just being so tired
after that
um and scared because it it was
unpredictable but when I heard him say
he's a person of interest
he's moving I just thought I've got to
get through this got to get through this
but they didn't realize I understood and
you'll put on trial it's a I mean it's a
puppet trying it was yeah
um you
I've seen the pictures of it I mean you
look for 50 days of just bread and water
if we were lucky we got bread it's
frightening to see like I see you now
and then you you you're in a really bad
way you're so thin your head shaved you
look malnourished you look really unwell
were you quite broken at that point sure
no not at all
I I was very
I thought we'd starve before we'd ever
get to trial that was the only I said to
people when I talk about this I said the
food and the starvation was the hardest
part then they sentenced you to death
but at this point you you think this
isn't I'm getting out of here so you how
I mean in that moment did you feel
afraid or did you think this they'll
never well I kind of hoping there was an
appeal system uh which they told us
there was so we weren't going to be put
to death straight away we knew again we
had value now they were up in the ante
don't get me wrong I was worried because
at some points we were just we're never
going to get out of it and it's just
getting worse
um so you know there was talk about how
they were going to shoot us the guards
would give us you know crap every day
saying we're going to shoot you with a
British bullet but then you get this
prison swap deal now that happens
between Russia and Ukraine it's it's
brokered by the Turks and the Saudis it
takes place in September did that just
come out of the Bluetooth we were just
settling in for the afternoon and they
said roll your stuff up you're going and
it was just initially
the best time
um we'd heard we might be going nobody
actually said to God said I think you
might be getting exchanged so we were
like great
um fantastic we were all putting a cell
together for the first time and we're
told to wait and then it was the worst
worst Journey can you tell us about this
horrific so ordeal you have before you
get to the plane Well we'd only got
outside the prison camp and handed over
to some guys who then just proceeded to
beat the crap out of us getting onto the
vehicle I've got a scar here where I was
just rammed into a door they hooded us
and and put some stress positions on the
back of the truck through Linkedin uh
and it's like a chain so basically yeah
a handcuffed to like in with plastic
like a masking tape around I'm bleeding
down my face it tasted blood red it just
ran me into the the door and then we
pick up Aiden at another prison in the
Croatian and loads of ukrainians so
we're thinking well what's going on here
so we travel for about an hour all in
the back of this vehicle uh it's very
hot really hot and then we were
separated from ukrainians when we
started worry a bit then hold on a
minute while we've been separated
um
we were still being beaten on this truck
but it got less and less the more we
moved into Russia there's some of the
guys thought we were going to zaparusia
but I had to tell them that I live
around here I know where we're going and
there's lights and I can hear small
propeller aircraft coming over above and
I said there's a no-fly zone over Mary
April so we're definitely in Russia
um and over the course of the night we
were there from three o'clock in the
afternoon to and we got to rostov about
nine o'clock in the morning the
following morning still in the position
we left on this back of this transport
um uh you know bleeding it was only when
we got off into the terminal I saw how
bad everybody was I had blood all down
my face you've just told me this story
The ordeal right what you went through
and then you're about to get to freedom
and then there's another beating and
there's and yeah and you must have
thought am I actually going to Freedom
or am I going to my death we were like
knew we were in Russia because they were
all Russian fatigues
so generally um
we didn't really know what was happening
and when we went to determinal it just
confused things even more there were
Saudis guys walking around arrows
walking around the terminal and we just
thought are we being sold on what the
hell's happening here where are we going
now you get on the plane is this the
moment you think
I'm going home no uh we were still
unsure and we just saw anyway it's got
to be better in here
um and we we got marched one at a time
onto the plane it was an unmarked plane
so we were even more
worried about where we were going and
what we were doing but then these guys
and Suits Mets on the plane that were
really nice and then we got moved into
these chairs that were like lazy boys on
a on an aircraft and suddenly it was
like
plush gold trim and carpets and we were
like what on Earth is going on here have
you been cleaned up at this point no we
were still so you're on this luxurious
yeah
like covered in blood and then while we
were sitting down the Saudis had given I
told us basically the door would shut
and he said you're not free until you
get to Russian airspace but you're free
um and that's where we know we just
broke down a lot of us and uh really
upset that we you know after what we've
just been for a year pretty much
um and then I went to the toilet to put
on these clothes they give us in a in a
bag once we've taken off we had food
um you know we were starving beer no no
no beer is a Saudi flight so there's no
beers on there we had cigarettes though
we were allowed to smoke on the plane
which was amazing
um I came out the toilet and this guy
looked at me went where are you from I
said London I said where are you from
and he says London I said you know I
look like Ryan Abramovich he said I am
very surreal yeah and then I quickly
said uh why didn't you buy West Ham and
he straight away said because Chelsea's
closer to my house I'm gonna have my
first introduction so we're just eating
and smoking and chilling and just
sitting
wow we're out and how what about a
primovich I mean I mean on the one hand
she must have been extremely grateful
that he helped broker your release but
on the other hand he's been a long-term
friend of Pete and who I imagine you
absolutely detest yeah uh it's a
difficult I mean I thanked him uh he
said explain to me that working more in
Herman and hearing aid for the war and
the people that affected by the war
um told me what his group's doing which
are you know I'll be indebted to
whatever part he played in it
um I don't hate Russians I hate Russian
foreign policy by extent the Army in
Ukraine yeah I refuse to believe that
all Russians support this war even
though with what's happened to me I
don't think you can hate a whole nation
um I know from experience that there's
humanitarian uh aspects to the other
side even if they do believe in Putin
and Putin
yeah my personal belief is that there
can't be any peace while he's in charge
you can't trust him he's uh forced
narratives that even on me to get an
agenda out there that we were all Nazis
is just
horrendous
[Music]
and to think with mercenary terrorists
when he's got Wagner who a whole uh you
know private group of soldiers which is
very hypocritical
um and also you know DPR have foreign
Fighters fighting for them that believe
in Russia's course so you know to go
forward out and be tortured and
ridiculed on propaganda I don't think I
could ever forgive those guys you know
but you know deep down I want an end to
resolve to this but do you want I want
Ukraine to win I want my home back in
Maryland and you're home now
that must have been your home in the UK
yeah you've obviously got your home in
Ukraine yeah you want to go back there
Larissa is there yeah how hard was it to
come back to the UK or was it just a
massive relief to be at peace it was a
relief to get back
um to to the UK uh to be out of that
yeah but part of me was really upset
that I didn't get exchanged with the
rest of my guys I'd spent so long with
you were also awarded the order of
Courage by President zelenski yeah how
did that feel really good to get some
recognition uh yeah we've got a
presidential decree uh for for uh
selfless sex in the sovereignty in the
defense of Ukraine so it was really nice
to get some some sort of recognition for
the time but you know we're still
dealing with Mario opal it's it's not
the prison time that's the thing we're
still dealing with uh Mario Opel which
is we won't deal with until this war
ends you will go home if you can to
Ukraine is that home for you now yeah
it's uh I managed to retire there before
The Invasion uh eventually I wanted to
settle down there I love Ukraine I've
been there five years I love the UK you
know but for me I've got so much
enjoyment out of living in Mario portal
denipro Kiev I'd been out there for so
long I really did enjoy enjoy uh living
out there and my aim is that when this
war finishes we can still do that one
day you think you're home on the Left
Bank was on the Left Bank you said
you're home personally yeah I want to
liberate Mario Paul and I don't see why
Ukraine should uh talk about peace yet
with Putin because one he can't be
trusted and two you know if there's the
world to fight the ukrainians and they
want to push and they're defending their
homes
they've got nothing else yeah yeah one
of the things I say to people is how
much of America or Norway or Britain
would you be willing to lose to talk
peace that if America would give up an
inch especially Britain wouldn't so you
know Ukraine is exactly the same it's
Ukrainian why do if we give an inch now
they'll come back in three years five
years push a bit more like they've done
with Crimea finally you're a year or
we're all this a year into this brutal
War the ukrainians have inspired the
world in their bravery before the war
started you taught to Sky News about the
role of the army and despite Russian
military superiority over the ukrainians
that they would give Rush with bloody
nose they've achieved more than that
haven't they yeah absolutely more so you
think they will be victorious
it's going to be a slog and a real tall
order they need to continue to support
we I think if you asked any of the fun
fights over there they just want support
they never wanted boots on the ground
they just need support and they do need
that and those fighter jets as well yeah
for me personally yeah I know the
logistics behind it I know how difficult
it is to train but that's not my part I
just want fighter jets and then to be
delivered in your message to Peyton I
wasn't expecting that but yeah
I just I one day he'll be found out
eventually he'll be found out Sean thank
you for telling us your story it's
incredible it's a miracle you'll sit in
front of me yeah I'm lucky
an extraordinary story Sean Pinner there
discussing the traumatic events he's
been through over the past year I hope
you found our conversation interesting
if you scan this QR code on screen now
you can watch all of our interviews
online and all of the previous episodes
of the show and if you scan the QR code
on screen right now you can listen to
Beth Rigby interviews podcast each week
I take a look at the highlights of the
interviews and there are some extra bits
and pieces in there too on my favorite
subject of politics that's on the Sky
News app or wherever you get your
podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you so much to my guest Sean Penner and
thank you for watching
[Music]